.
Tanya Beaumont.
.c vérif
(musique thème de "James Bond")
♪ ♪ ♪
- Comme le diamant,
cette musique de film est
éternelle. Le thème de
"James Bond" est aussi célèbre
que son agent.
PIERRE-OLIVIER ROY, chargé
d'enseignement, Université Laval
- Le thème qu'on reconnaît
le plus de James Bond, c'est
le terme de l'agent 007.
C'est ce qu'on entend avec
la guitare, avec l'orchestre,
avec des cuivres. C'est ce qui
donne la signature
de James Bond, ce qu'on appelle
un leitmotiv. Le leitmotiv,
c'est un thème qui est associé
à un personnage.
- Où est 007?
- Attendre la sortie au grand
écran de la 25e aventure
de James Bond, "Mourir peut
attendre", l'orchestre
symphonique du Québec présente
un concert autour de l'univers
musical de l'agent 007.
STEPHANIE MARTIN, chanteuse du
groupe invité Jeans'n Classics
- La musique de James Bond,
c'est des grands thèmes,
c'est épique, c'est dramatique,
alors c'est des grands thèmes
qui se marient très bien avec
l'orchestre symphonique.
♪ You will never see me cry ♪
♪ There is just no time to die ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- Chaque film de la franchise
propose une chanson qui a
le potentiel de devenir aussi
populaire que le long-métrage.
- Depuis le début, il y a
toujours une affiliation entre
un artiste populaire très connu,
très en vogue, qui représente
son époque et les films
de James Bond.
♪ You only live twice ♪
♪ Oh! so it seems ♪
- C'est un exercice technique
difficile de chanter
la petite voix douce
de Nancy Sinatra ou de
Sheena Easton, entre autres
et puis après de chanter
les grosses tounes qui demandent
beaucoup plus de voix puis
beaucoup plus de puissance
vocale.
♪ For mister Goldfinger ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ Pretty girl,
beware of this heart of gold ♪
- Il n'y a qu'une chanteuse
qui est revenue à plusieurs
reprises, Shirley Bassey, qui
est la chanteuse, la chanteuse
de "Goldfinger", qui est
une grande chanteuse
à voix dont la voix surplombe
habituellement les orchestres
majestueux, très "ballroom".
C'est une signature importante
cette sonorité-là, on entend
beaucoup de cuivres, des grandes
cordes, une grande voix, ça a
marqué l'histoire des
"James Bond" jusqu'à Adèle.
♪ Let the sky fall ♪
♪ When it crumbles ♪
- Souvent le caractère qui est
associé à l'artiste choisit
vient aussi dans le même sens
que ce qu'on veut donner comme
personnalités au James Bond.
- Le concert passera à travers
toutes les époques
des James Bond, de Sean Connery
à Daniel Crai